[Music]
neither human help nor Imperial
munificence nor all the modes of
pocketing heaven could stifle scandal or
dispel the belief that the fire had
taken place by order therefore to Scotch
the rumour
Nero substituted his culprits and
punished with the utmost refinements of
cruelty a class of men loathed for their
vices whom the crowd styled Christians
Christ as the founder of the name had
undergone the death penalty in the reign
of Tiberius by sentence of the
procurator Pontius Pilatus and the
pernicious superstition was checked for
a moment only to break out once more not
merely in Judea the home of the disease
but in the capital itself were all
things horrible or shameful in the world
collect and find a vogue first then the
confessed members of the sect were
arrested next on their disclosures vast
numbers were convicted not so much on
the count of arson as for hatred of the
human race and derision accompanied
their end they were covered with wild
beasts skins and torn to death by dogs
or they were fastened on crosses and
when daylight failed were burned to
serve as lamps by night Nero had offered
his gardens for the spectacle and gave
an exhibition to his circus mixing with
the crowd in the habit of a charioteer
were mounted on his car
hence in spite of guilt which had earned
the most exemplary punishment there
arose a sentiment of pity
due to the impression that they were
being sacrificed not for the welfare of
the state but to the ferocity of a
single man
[Music]
you